hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're gonna talk about the two most
ignored minerals and diabetes okay so
this is really cool information this is
very powerful if you are a diabetic or
if you're a pre-diabetic and you have
infinite resistance and what I mean by
that is if you have belly fat if you
have a fatty liver if you're tired after
eating
if you can't go between meals without
being very hungry if you feel better
when you eat if you have swell a swollen
belly if you actually have sweet
cravings or high blood pressure those
are all signs of insulin resistance if
you have that you this videos for you
there are two minerals one is potassium
and one is magnesium
now magnesium makes an enzymes to help
lower the blood sugar faciem is involved
with helping the storage of sugar called
glycogen so your body will store sugar
in between meals and your liver and your
muscles so if you don't have that
capacity it could be because you don't
have no potassium but here's the thing
that's that people don't realize insulin
triggers the absorption uptake of both
potassium and magnesium in the cell
without insulin you cannot absorb
magnesium or potassium okay so right
there that's going to create a
deficiency and then both of these
actions to lower the blood sugars and
the storage of glycogen aren't gonna
happen so you have a double-edged sword
so what happens is when you increase
magnesium and potassium or just normal
if you just have the normal amount you
can decrease the need for instance you
can actually help heal the sensitivity
to glucose and the insulin resistance
and I'm gonna put some links down below
that there's studies that show that you
can take these two minerals and greatly
improve if not fix insulin resistance of
course you have to change your diet and
things like that but that's very very
amazing that these two minerals can
actually lower the need for insulin and
then when you lower the need for insulin
now you have enough insulin to pull in
these minerals into the cell and it just
will all work out real nicely okay now
the other thing is that hypercalcemia
that's too much calcium
if you look that up and I put a link
down below that can cause diabetes
that's one of the interesting side
effects from having hypercalcemia cause
of diabetes
probably because when you have too much
calcium calcium it can lock up magnesium
because calcium magnesium work together
so if you have soft tissue calcium and
spurring arthritis and things like that
or taking tums or calcium carbonate you
know you're not taking up magnesium just
straight calcium carbonate you know
especially if you're an anti acids that
can set you up for diabetes interesting
that's probably also why vitamin d3 in
k2 improve diabetes as well I put some
links down below for that too so
probably because this mobilizes the
calcium and frees up the magnesium so
how can you get these minerals well this
will happens they're both in the same
food vegetables yeah so we keep coming
back to this vegetable thing right you
need 7 to 10 cups of vegetables every
single day you can do in the blender you
can do it in a salad it's not that hard
but it's very important to get that
amount because if you're doing 7 to 10
cups to your potassium you're gonna
easily get the magnesium because
magnesium is in the fan vegetables you
don't need as much you need about take
450 milligrams but you need 4700
milligrams of potassium so here's what I
want you to do for the next week go
ahead and start consuming more
vegetables you'll increase these and
just see if any of these symptoms start
going away then you'll know that this is
what caused or contributed to your
problem in the first place alright
thanks for watching oh and I'll check
out your comments below